good afternoon kentucky
we're going to start today
by several of us making comments on the
announcement
today from the grand jury and from the
attorney general on the brianna taylor
investigation and then after those
comments and any questions i'm going to
provide
a brief coveted report
as governor you can do a lot of things
and some people think you can do just
about anything
but as governor i cannot control
decisions made by an attorney general's
office
i cannot control decisions made by a
grand jury
and i don't lead local law enforcement
offices
what i can control is how i lead
what i say what i'm committed
to doing i start with the humility
and acknowledgement that i will never
feel the weight
of 400 years of slavery segregation
and jim crow i will never
personally feel that way but i can
listen
and i can try to hear and i can be clear
that systematic racism exists in this
world
in this country and in our commonwealth
it exists in unequal access to health
care
in disproportionate incarceration rates
and it impacts everything
from wealth earnings education even
how long we live on this earth
my faith teaches me that injustices
and inequalities must be addressed
the world that god calls on us to build
is one without
racism one without oppression
one without violence since the start of
my administration we have worked to
combat
some of these inequalities
we've restored voting rights we've
protected and expanded healthcare
and we have built an inclusive team
but as i listen and as i try to hear
i know that there is so much more work
to be done
there are hundreds of years of pain to
be addressed
and my job is to continue to listen to
try to hear
and to do everything i can to build the
type of world that i think
everybody's kids deserve one where we
live up to our true values
one where we live up to our faith one
where we try to make a dream
talked about many decades ago closer to
reality today the attorney general
announced a mixture of the findings of
his investigation
and the decisions of the grand jury
we appreciate his communication with us
leading up
to the announcement it allowed us to
take steps that we needed to
to take regarding louisville
and communication leading all the way up
to
the announcement in the announcement he
described
the investigation but he talked about
information facts evidence
that neither i nor the general public
have seen
i believe that the public deserves this
information
so i previously made what i would call a
suggestion to the attorney general
and now i'm making the request
that he posts online all the information
evidence and facts that he can release
without impacting the three felony
indictments
the three felony counts in the
indictment issued today
everyone can and should be informed
and those that are currently feeling
frustration
feeling hurt they deserve to know
more i trust kentuckians they deserve to
see the facts
for themselves and i believe that the
ability to process
those facts helps everybody
and i believe that no matter what
somebody's perspective is
on today's announcement that they
believe having
the full amount of information out there
and these have been posted by
other prosecutors across the nation in
different situations
is hopefully something that can help us
talk to each other
help us heal help us move forward
and help us always to make uh
improvements
i'm going to turn it over to
someone who i get to work with every day
someone who's real advice i've relied
upon
that has been a district judge has been
the deputy
attorney general has been someone that
has experienced more than i could ever
claim to
and that is j michael brown and once
he's done we're going to hear from
representative booker
thank you governor
not expecting to stand here today it's a
different role for me in this situation
but over these last few weeks many times
as we sat in his office and we've
discussed what's going on
not just in louisville but in the world
the governors look to me
i think because of not only have i spent
40 decades
four decades in the law but i've lived
through
a lot of things um haven't been blessed
to be 71 years old now
i've seen uh
assassinations of
john f kennedy martin luther king robert
kennedy and malcolm x
i've seen disturbances in the street
i was born before brown versus board of
education
i was alive when the civil rights act
passed
i served my country in a time when we
were supposedly changing hearts and
minds and
thought that was the right thing to do
at the time don't regret it
but i've come to recognize that
sometimes the effort to just change
hearts and minds is not enough
that we really need to change behavior
justice on certain changes not just in
behavior but in process
i think the first involves some
technological issues
we are rules of evidence that were
developed sometimes hundreds of years
ago hasn't caught up to technology which
developed in the last
10 minutes so much i also believe that
the public has developed an expectation
rightfully so
that government and those in the
criminal justice system will present to
them
information that they can understand in
a way that they can understand
regardless of what it is there are
certain things which are facts
whether it's a photograph whether it's a
tape recording whether it's a report
that won't change over the course of a
tribunal
and won't necessarily prejudice either
the defendant
with the presumption of innocence or the
prosecution whose job it is to seek
justice a prosecutor's job
is to seek justice i'm not going to try
to explain much about what happened with
the brianna taylor
situation in the grand jury although i
would encourage everyone to learn more
about how our system
really works with a grand jury and what
these indictments are and what these
charges
are or are not and i would have hoped
that more of that explanation would have
come out from a variety of
sources before we got to today's result
i think what happened was a situation
where
expectations were built up that were not
necessarily
based on a full knowledge of what the
legal standards were
and therefore when those expectations
were not met their severe
disappointment but in that
disappointment i live in
louisville and obviously in kentucky
which i've
served for a number of years and in this
country which i've served
faithfully for a number of years i would
hope that we don't take a regressive
step
forward in changing behaviors
and we really change behaviors and
brianna taylor's legacy is that it can
change behavior because more of the
world when you saw
demonstrations in countries that really
don't have anything to do with
louisville kentucky you know that it's
widespread
and i want to make one other comment
before i step down because it struck me
you know on june 25th i was here in this
capitol
out and around it when until freedom
had a demonstration here and they have
many speakers
including um mr crump who i've met known
from previous uh you know engagements so
to speak spoke to him out on the veranda
there
one of the speakers that day was common
and it was very eloquent but there was
something ringing in my head from common
and it came from the fact that sometimes
i used to hear him almost every morning
driving back
forth to frankfort people talk about
being woke
well there is a song and it's called
wake up everybody
and john legend and common uh
teamed up and they made a wonderful
version of it and there's what we would
call a rap part of it in the middle
of it which i think those words
apply right now i'm not going to read
the whole thing
but here's what common says in in a
rhythm that only i wish i could recreate
he says though i'm the type to bear arms
and wear my heart on my sleeve even
when i fell in god i believe breathing
the days weave through the maze and the
seasons so amazing
feed them raise them seasons are aging
earthquakes wars and rumors i want us to
get by
but we're more than consumers we're more
than
shooters we're more than looters created
in his image
so god lived through us and even in this
generation
living through through computers only
love love
love can reboot us
let's follow the principles echoed by
common and martin luther king and a lot
of other people
let's strike the consciences of people
and not the fears in people and we can
continue the change
that led to the point where my next
speaker could walk these halls in the
general assembly
or i could hold the position that i do
now in state government
i represent the 43rd district
but to be more precise i represent the
wealth of kentucky
and a lot of people who feel a lot of
pain
right now
um i listened to
words by of a giant
making it clear that just me being here
is a testament to what progress can look
like
i feel that weight right now
and our community
has been through so much this year
uh but it speaks to generations of pain
and inequity
and in this moment right now the first
thing that i want to do
is recognize miss palmer
and brianna's family
i have the dog tag from my cousin tj
i carry with me every day
they are dealing with trauma and pain
that will never really go away they have
grieved before an entire nation
the world even has seen their heart
break
and i know that today was just another
painful chapter
in a path of of healing
of reconciling what can never fully be
reconciled
because briana taylor should be alive
today
and i also want to acknowledge
a community of people who have risen up
in protest calling for justice
even in the face of being
ignored hit with tear gas
pepper bullets demonized
called names they've shown up
every day people like
my family mr cortez and call them c tess
stachelle coutura
shamika so many folks that
helped us ring out the cry for brianna
taylor's name
not simply to account for what the
officers did
that's critical we'll talk about that
we're talking about that
but also to call out the fact that we
have to do the deep-rooted work
that justice isn't just about what
happens to these officers it never was
just about what happens to these
officers it was always
about the fact that we have generations
of poverty and inequity
all across our commonwealth that so many
people
feel the fear of knowing that justice
may not account for their humanity
i talk about it often in this building
and the truth of the matter is today
their strength is why i have so much
hope
in spite of what some may want to do and
seeking to
cast and divide us and make this a
conversation about
some versus others we realize as a
collective as a commonwealth because the
people that are marching
come from all corners all walks of life
we realize that this moment is about
family
and i'm proud of that truth
let's be clear justice failed
us today it felt us in a way that has
been failing us for generations
we are here doing this work i was
elected to do this work because we need
to make justice ring true
because it has failed a woman
black woman was killed in her home by
the agency paid for to protect
and serve her
that's wrong there is no justifying that
and if it calls on us and it does call
on us
to change laws to lift up brianna's law
but to do so much more
in accountability and reimagining public
safety in a true sense
which is not simply more and more
law enforcement being called on to be
everything public safety
we have to do that work if we really
want to honor brianna and
when i leave here i will go home to the
west end of louisville
i will see a lot of people that i love
dearly
hurting even in the streets
and i want to speak to them the last
thing i'll say
um this moment to me to us
is about protecting the movement
all of us all across the commonwealth of
kentucky
as family we have to do the work
to make sure that we can all be free and
have the liberty of being safe
in our homes to make sure that we all
have the opportunity
to pursue our dreams brianna wanted to
take care of people
she should be here to pursue her dreams
we all need to commit to making
community mean
something to making democracy mean
something to making justice
mean something and i'm asking you all
from every corner of this commonwealth
lift your voices keep demanding change
keep leading for change run
for office yourself i'm a living witness
of that
but don't be quiet don't slow down and
most importantly
lean in with love love is what's going
to get us through this
love for our commonwealth love for one
another love for our future
our faith in one another our faith
that justice can finally ring true
let's cling to that now together
and keep one another safe
and uh we'll get through this so that's
what kentucky does
that's what we're made of we'll get
through this together
and we will try the course with
leadership
does not hide behind the law
where leadership can show the courage to
speak the truth and be accountable
for the lives of all of us even if it's
a life
and especially if it's the life of a
black woman
where our leaders won't preach to us and
condemn us and try to tell us how to
express our pain but we'll acknowledge
our pain
and hear our cries and be accountable to
them we're going to realize that
um brianna thank you for being the light
we'll keep fighting honor your name
thank you representative all right we'll
open it up for
questions on on this
and then um afterwards i'll give a
quick update on a pandemic that we are
still fighting
that disproportionately is taking other
lives
so we'll start over here with you karen
the attorney general was inside
listening um and as everything was
announced one
said uh the divide is greater now
than it has ever been and it seems like
every time we take a few steps forward
we get shoved back
could you respond they wanted me to pass
it the question is
is about some some individuals who
apparently had had gathered outside the
history center
and and to express feelings that
divide is greater than ever and that
and then we're moving backwards
every time they take a few steps forward
they get shoved back
well first i want to make sure that i
listen to and hear that pain
and that frustration many people think
your your job as governor is to get up
here and talk and i know i've had to
talk a lot
um but sometimes it's to make sure
that you are hearing especially
experiences that
may be different from yours but also
your sincere belief that there's a
commonwealth where everybody counts
and where there are systematic issues
like racism
we have to know that they are impacting
the lives of kentuckians
unfairly preventing so many from
reaching their potential
and we've seen even even before some of
this or or i've seen
the amount of of pain that is out there
but i hope they realize our commitment
at least my commitment in these halls
and what's considered the
most important uh office in the
commonwealth that
uh i want to do better and that
personally means i got to be better
um i'm going to continue to listen
because i know that the best ideas and
the way we move forward aren't just
going to come from me
maybe maybe none of those ideas come
from me but they are ideas that we are
going to be able to put in place
hopefully change the commonwealth and
change the world if we sincerely
believe that we have a true duty to one
another
and to our god to build the world that i
think he or she requires of us
ryland
attorney general to release the
investigative file if requested
the question is does the open records
act
require the attorney general to release
the file
if requested um obviously i was attorney
general
um up until about nine months ago
uh ten months ago it moves fast
um and and and we had to make a lot of
those uh
decisions um there are differences
between a prosecutor's file and an
investigatory file
and then there are requirements that
that something is
final uh but but what i can say is
regardless of what the open records law
requires
given that today's announcement
only related to a specific officer
and shots that were fired that reached a
different apartment
it would seem that the investigation and
or any further movement
uh on on on other actions that occurred
that night are done
and that there can't be any prejudicing
any jury that's
that's out there because according to
today's announcement there won't be any
and so i think that it's time um to
release those ballistics reports and and
and listen i want to i appreciate that
the attorney general talked in detail
about them
those are the types of facts that can
help us process
and he talked through it today and he
didn't shy away from the fact that there
was inconsistency in them
again i trust people if they are able to
get that information
and so what i'd like to see is all that
put online
those pieces of evidence those reports
so that people can truly read them
and process them and the conversations
we need to have moving into the future
if they're about this specific incident
can be based on it or if there are
things we can learn and i think we all
agree and
everyone law enforcement and other agree
that that
we should learn every single time that
there is a tragic occurrence about what
we can do better mark
it's about generations of inequity and
inequality so
what can the state of kentucky do to
change that and do you have any
proposals that you're thinking about in
governor's
budget to try to address that so a
question comes off
representative booker's uh eloquence and
speaking his truth
and thank you for for doing that today
that's what these walls of this capital
should be about uh and and that's what
we all need to hear and listen and i
hope everybody out there
is hearing and listening and and
representative booker talked about how
justice
deals with hundreds of years of
inequities and
and i believe that that we have to start
directly
addressing them and be intentional about
it uh every day
and one that i've been intensely focused
on is healthcare because
in the midst of covid we have seen our
black and african-american
kentuckians dying at twice the rate they
make up of the population
and it's no secret why it is
inadequate access to health care this is
something that dr king talked about
so many years ago about being one of the
the greatest forms of inequality and
shame on us for not
solving and resolving that before now
we've launched a campaign
uh directly aimed at the black and
african-american community aimed at
signing every single individual up for
some form
of health care that's going on uh right
now
and we're gonna we're gonna move further
after that to get everybody in the
commonwealth
signed up for health care but i'd like
to think that step
is finally showing priority for a
community that
for far too long we haven't shown a
priority for it's about building
wealth not just creating jobs in an area
but building
wealth in a community uh where where
we haven't provided those opportunities
providing educational opportunities and
knowing different things that we have to
do to get there
you know there are studies that show
it's a fact
that an african-american teacher
can have a incredible impact
on minority students and you see that in
in the outcome we got to step up
work with our hbcus to make sure that we
have those programs in place and we are
continuing to improve it
we need more programs to to recruit more
black and african-american kentuckians
into our law enforcement
to ensure that law enforcement and
everything else look like
the rest of our commonwealth we've got
to make sure that we don't have laws
whether it's insurance or
or others that make it harder for some
individuals
to move ahead in different ways than
others banking laws too
and for years we have had programs
rightfully so
that invest in eastern kentucky and
invest in in western kentucky i made
those announcements
we need those same type of programs and
i proposed one in our budget this last
year
that invests in in areas like west
louisville
it's time for us to to step up and do
our part
so that for me and what it keeps coming
back in the next pandemic
we're not just repeating the same things
because
we've seen and we're hearing about the
pain of this
individual situation today
but the pain in a pandemic where
systematic racism in our health care
system has resulted in countless more
people dying than they should is one
that
is one that i feel every day reading off
the
counties and and the ages
one more before you oh i'm sorry yeah do
you believe
justice was done today well i believe
the question is do i believe that
justice was done today
being a former prosecutor and attorney
general i think that we need to see
the facts the evidence
and and that i hope moving forward
there's more explanation of process
and of what certain things uh require
uh i know that the that that mrs palmer
who who i've met who stood
right here actually we were in the
supreme court's got to be in a lot of
pain today and i can't imagine losing
one of my children
um but i think having more of the facts
out there
to where people can see and people can
truly uh
process it is is where we need to be the
attorney general spoke today about the
truth and
i agree our commitments to the truth i'd
just ask him to provide more of the
tools for everyone to
to to be able to evaluate and to
determine
what that truth is i never expected when
i was attorney general for people just
to rely upon my judgment
i wanted to make sure that people saw
the reasons for for what we're doing
and there's still the opportunity to to
do that there i don't think that there
was a response today to a question about
what might be forthcoming there tom and
then catherine
and representative secretary
since representative booker obviously
talks to the people of his community
secretary brown's got you know past
experience in the legal world you're a
former ag
is there anything that you have been
able to
detect thus far that perhaps the
investigation
was flawed in any way
so the question is have i um
have i have i determined that the
investigation
uh was flawed in any way i i'd need to
see
the evidence i need to see uh the
statements i need to see
what was and and and wasn't done uh to
to have any comment on
that um i think that everybody looking
back
um wishes that
that um
think things have been like not in the
end
since but certainly what happened uh
that night
and there have been a number of things
suggested since that i think shed a
little bit of light
uh on that about um what it ought to
take
to get a no knock warrant even though
when it was executed apparently
um there's there's a question about
whether it was executed as a no knock
warrant
who should be able to execute a no knock
warrant what type of training that takes
because that's a very different
situation in most parts of our state
law enforcement never uh conduct one
uh and most of the time at least what
has been explained to me it's conducted
by
a highly trained group and and and unit
what type of surveillance needs to be
done
ahead of time before one uh to again uh
reduce the the risks these are all
things
moving forward that we need to look at
both from a process standpoint
and as a as a legal standpoint um
you know if if i had a wish and i and
and i talked about it during
the investigation period it was just for
more explanation
i think people need to understand
process they need to understand
elements and that's not talking down to
people it's just giving people
information
that i think that they need to take what
they hear
and and put it into some type of context
when we have such a vacuum
and something that we are so passionate
or so frustrated or
uh when we have a vacuum of of
information it makes it so much
harder um on us personally and
emotionally and and those that are
involved do you want to add to that or
okay catherine
demonstrators who are taking to the
streets tonight who are upset with
hearing this decision the question is
what's my message to demonstrators
well first i will listen
and i want to hear and i truly
want a better world for your kids and
for mine
and while this is an unfair inequitable
world to your kids then my kids aren't
living in the right world
either i believe that i have a duty to
my faith into my commonwealth
to make sure that we do so much better
and i want to be a partner moving
forward
i will never ever tell someone not to
give voice to their truth
or to speak out for what they believe in
but
i would ask that we not engage
in any type of violence and that we not
put ourselves
in a position and the people not put
themselves in a position
where someone can hijack
what they are trying to do can try to
incite violence around them we've
already seen some militia groups walking
through
downtown louisville so be safe
and and the eyes of the world are on
louisville
people will hear there are more cameras
um broadcasting to more uh places
uh and so i'd be mindful that that
they're here but also that that you're
heard and let's try to do this in a way
that makes positive change and is not
used
to prevent change joe
[Music]
talk about several aspects of the
process
such as whether prosecutors recommended
smooth investments or not
the racial makeup of the grand jury
stuff like that
is do you think that those are part of
the library report that you should
reveal publicly
uh the question is is about different uh
questions the attorney general's asked
today about the grand jury proceeding
and you do have to be careful in a grand
jury proceeding
about what you can and can't disclose
though there have been
situations one was after the fact but in
ferguson where
uh transcripts and evidence were were
released
almost uh in in the whole
i certainly think that a legitimate
question is the
uh racial and demographic makeup of the
grand jury
i think that that's something that that
i hope they reconsider
responding to i mean in a city of
louisville that is
already so diverse i don't think it will
give out anybody's identity
or compromise who they are
and and provided that it is sufficiently
diverse it may give people um
just just another piece of information
uh that that they can process
leave the expectations were too high for
people going into this about the
repercussions that would happen to the
officers that were involved in that
the question is did i believe the
expectations were too high for people
uh leading into this and and you know
secretary brown
um is is uh speaking his truth based on
on his experience i i don't know exactly
where people's
expectations uh were but i believe it's
really hard to
put in context a decision today without
knowing
what it took to get to that decision or
what it would take to get to another
decision i know that especially when
you're hurt
that that without explanation in a
vacuum of information
it could be it can be incredibly
uh tough and and that that
it's not viewed in isolation there are
other incidents that have gone on
around the united states now there were
an indictment today with three felony
charges
but i think i think trusting people with
the information
and putting it out there so that um at
least they can evaluate
i just think that that's that's the
right thing to do
and and again we i think general cameron
believes in truth and i believe in truth
i just like for people to see the
information so they can determine
the truth and kentucky are enforced
appropriately
do you think there's any room for reform
in that aspect
the question is do i think drug crimes
are are enforced
correctly in kentucky and what are some
potential changes there
but first obviously we have an addiction
crisis
in the state i believe that the way the
best way to
to address that is to help people get
better and to give especially kids but
people as they grow older the tools to
not fall into addiction in the first
place but then
the job skills and and the help that
people need to get out of it
and to and to stay out of it and i will
say the only way i believe we
we win the the war on drugs if it's if
it's still even that
is is to help people not to incarcerate
people
uh it's it's about impacting the demand
and and not the
the supply you know there are so many
really dangerous drugs out there i
understand why we have
enforcement when we have things like
fentanyl
that can kill you the first time you try
it or even harm people when they touch
it we have to recognize that
now i also think that it's never a wrong
thing to step back
and to look at actions we take in any um
of our processes processes i was just
talking with
secretary brown who was working with the
city of louisville when they
ended up high-speed pursuits
by law enforcement based on what can
happen and the danger that it can create
and so i certainly think that it's
something that we can all look at
in a form of improvement about when you
would undertake
certain activity you know based on on
the likely harm coming out of it but
also
the harm to other people uh that can
that can occur
do one more we'll go i'll get you
go ahead karen there there was some fear
and anger today
um and have been over the last few days
of police presence and then downtown in
frankfort people notice snipers of
course the national guard
um presence so there's concern that
there's an expectation
now of violence could you reiterate why
those measures are being taken
the question is why certain measures are
being taken from a law enforcement
standpoint
i do want to make sure i mention one
thing there's a question the question
included people in downtown frankfurt
including
and the term was used uh snipers though
those are not snipers and i want to make
sure that
i i understand um so so in any
circumstance
uh where state police or others are
trying to ensure secured they doing a
high vantage point
so that they are able to see what's
going on all around that's that's
standard
um and that's not intending to put
anybody uh in a quote unquote uh
sniper uh position uh our goal
and and today i authorized a limited
deployment of the national guard
our goal is to make sure that we can
keep
everybody safe we've got a militia
walking around
i think they broke with the three
percenters down
downtown we've got
others would take what is otherwise a
peaceful rally demonstration protest
and would like nothing more than to see
uh uh people harmed we've got some
critical infrastructure i'll give you an
example hospitals
right now that we have to make sure uh
stay open and aren't disrupted in a time
of covet or or anything else
i know that it can be hard to see
that presence and i know that there are
some that disagree with it but i can
tell you from my standpoint
and why it's being done is to make sure
that
anyone and everyone can express their
first amendment rights
but that they can do so safely that
no one can can incite violence and that
um and that that critical infrastructure
can can continue to operate in times
where it where it has to
riley a little more
can you this is something that a lot of
people are really scared of when they
hear that the national park has been
deployed
what assurances can you provide that
basically what happened
in late may you know with david mcatee
at 26th and broadway
it doesn't happen again the question is
on the national guard and
it's hard to believe as governor in
different ways i think i've had to
deploy the national guard five separate
times
now some of those are to assist county
clerks in voting and others but this is
certainly during covid remember at one
point we had them at
hospitals when we thought that could be
a rush and wanting to make sure there's
uh order there you know i can assure
citizens of louisville that
the national guard deployment
is limited it's based on very specific
operations and that is under the command
of the national guard
and and no one else uh that that
um each of the the guardsmen or women
know what uh their job is and it's not
the forward-facing role that
lmpd is is playing and has much more
experience with
my commitment is is to make sure that
something like what happened to mr
mcatee regardless of the reasons that
it happens
again because regardless of the
circumstances of
of of that situation which are are a
part of litigation right now
we want to make sure everybody
absolutely everybody is safe
throughout this this deployment is much
more similar to derby
much more limited in scope to what
happened previously
and again there is a different command
structure in place this time and you can
bet i'm getting updates as frequently as
as i can mark
two or three specific pieces of
legislation the general assembly could
pass
this year that would either a
prevent future shootings like what we
saw with brianna kaler
or b address the generations of inequity
and poverty
so the uh the question was about
specific pieces of
legislation that could address uh the
circumstances involving um around
brianna taylor but then also the broader
conversation about inequity
and so we we already have that that has
been pre-filed
uh brianna's law that deals with no
knock warrants and also body cameras and
requirements with uh with that we
understand that's just a start
in the broader process um we have the
opportunity to expand
citizen review of police shootings and
secure subpoena for them that the
community has
more access to the information about
trauma that's affecting them
from the agency they pay for um
but in terms of like the broader
conversation of inequity there's a piece
of legislation that we're hearing more
about this
at the national level as it's been
elevated through covet
how we have impact assessments for every
piece of legislation
to determine how it impacts black
community
dealing with racism at a structural
level is going to require us to look at
every single policy
every budgetary decision and so
legislation like that
would be an important step to where
we're being intentional about
rooting out our blind spots and then i
think the governor was correct in terms
of how do we build wealth
and not just look at economic
opportunities in terms of jobs
that requires justice and it requires us
to have an investment in communities
that have been marginalized and
disadvantaged for generations
we have the opportunity to do that now
with small business
support with
training and capacity building but also
with direct justice
um at the national level has been
discussed for years
about reparations we should finally have
that conversation
in the commonwealth of kentucky we can
do those things together
as family all of us and i'm definitely
going to be a part of that even though i
won't be here
next year you'll keep hearing from me
that's for sure
i'll still be here of course
i'm pretty sure representative booker
will be here maybe a different title
but still be here tom
governor uh
we'll be looking into the process for
securing reviewing and executing search
warrants in kentucky and he said we'll
include citizens
members of the law enforcement community
the judiciary elected officials and what
have you
are you uh are you on board with that
and would you like to have your office
here
the questions on the ag's task force
that he proposed we would certainly
serve on that task force i think that it
is a good idea
it could perhaps be merged into
a group that's been meeting of
legislators administration
and others on on maybe a slightly wider
variety of topics it could be merged
into discussions we have had
with the black legislative caucus and
separately that i've had with with law
enforcement about
different ways um and and processes
that it could be better and so we always
should want to do things uh better uh so
no that's that is uh that is an idea
that we would be
uh more than happy to participate in
uh an action inertia movement
are are important
thank you state police you mentioned the
national guard mission how it's
so the questions on the kentucky state
police
there is also a limited group
of kentucky state police officers that
are
assisting in louisville but once again
they are their own unit
they are under kentucky state police
command
they are there to provide additional
assistance if needed
they have training more akin
to what lmpd has as opposed to some
of the guard but they'll be they'll be
serving
specific requests and missions but as
their own unit
uh in louisville
you just indicate that you're going to
give representative booker a job in your
administration
and two um i just i'm hoping to
understand this in their own command for
national guard
asp a little bit better i mean what
exactly does that mean i guess like are
they still going to be
they're not yeah so the it's a two-part
question one
representative booker and i have not
talked about a job to
to date i know he's got a lot going on
and and we've talked about some other
great initiatives
uh that he's pushing but we're always
open to have that other conversation
too uh the second piece is trying to
understand
what i meant and they're under their own
uh command
so um in in the initial uh
uh deployment to louisville uh during
especially those first couple nights
um where where things were concerning
the guard was
sent out around louisville based on
uh instruction command from lmpd we were
integrated if you will we while we will
have an lmpd officer with each group of
guardsmen or women that's necessary
because there's no police power in and
of itself in the guard
the guard is answering to the guard i
have the adjutant general
there in louisville back and forth we
have uh the command structure
on site while they are talking certainly
with lmpd
with federal agents and others that are
out there because there's more
uh groups this time than last time every
decision that's made as to where the
guards go and what the guard do is made
by the guard
likewise ksp decisions are made by ksp
and only ksp where are
talks at now regarding the possibility
of a special session to deal with police
reporting maybe
representative can also talk about this
what do you hope to actually
see out of those talks and out of a
possible special session
talks on a special session continue
the the things that i put out there that
we would be required to call a special
session though
we're still looking for and we're not at
yet number one
is that any any progress
would have to be substantial it can't be
window dressing it can't be done just to
look like
we are trying to do something it has to
mean that we are truly going to move the
commonwealth forward
i'm not into calling people here just
for a show
the the second is we have to have
agreement ahead of time it's sixty
thousand dollars a day
so we wanna make sure that uh that that
we have that
uh as we come in we are not there yet
but we have reached out to numerous
groups i believe that there is
some uh common ground i think it needs
to continue
to be refined and then the question is
what's possible today does it meet that
real progress
and if it doesn't even the the black
legislative caucus has said they want to
wait until the regular
session because again they don't believe
that
window dressing is appropriate just to
make a statement right now
that real progress is what's requested
all right now i know that um
but this is the issue on everybody's
hearts and mind today
and i hope those out there won't think
that that the the switch i've got to
make is callous but we are still dealing
with a worldwide health pandemic uh and
today we're reporting 796
new cases covet 19 111 of them
are in kids 18 or under it brings our
total number of cases to 63
517 and today we're reporting five new
deaths bringing our total death count to
1124.
so what i'd ask is everybody including
those that may
march tonight or those that are going to
go inside their house of worship which i
know was a call that was made
and one that i support please please
please
wear a mask especially if you're inside
with a group of people we need you to
wear
a mask no one would want to turn a
moment
of unity of giving voice of trying to
make progress into one that spreads a
virus so
please make sure you do it safely i know
you will
but this is so important when sadly
with inequality and health care when our
black or african-american community
members can track covid right now they
are more likely
than others to pass away from it we've
already talked about one tragic loss
today
let's make sure that that we prevent
others our positivity rate as of today
is 4.59 we had a significant number
of tests that came in we're now at
almost 1.3 million tests administered
since the beginning of covet 19.
those we've lost include a 99 year old
woman from christian
an 83 year old man from marshall an 84
year old woman from jefferson a 50 year
old man from jefferson
and an 81 year old female from
jefferson new cases by county 194 in
jefferson
56 in barron 38 in fayette 33 in warren
27 in davis 20 in hardin 18 in bullet
17 in whitley 16 in kenton and in knox
14 in boone 13 in estell henderson
madison montgomery oldham 12 and not
11 in scott and the rest are going to be
online also online we have
the the case the racial and ethnic
breakdown
it's it's been fairly stable but again
it shows
challenges that we have we hope later in
the week to have
halloween guidance the cdc is certainly
very different from where ohio
is and so that's an update we will have
further into the future
we've hit five so we'll ask people save
their coveted questions if you can for
tomorrow i want to thank you all for for
being here
and i wanted to be governor to to do
everything i could to build a better
world
um and i never knew different ways that
uh that we'd be called upon to to do
that
my prayer is that we can achieve that uh
my prayer is that
um i will be able to listen and hear
and and have the courage to do what's
necessary to
to create justice to move forward
and that all of us all of us
can do whether it's those small or those
big things
to move to closer to the world that i
think god calls us to create
thank you